[Musik]
wir begrüßen sie sehr herzlich zu
unserem ersten unter den linden spezial
zur bundestagswahl 2017 in den kommenden
tagen werden mein kollege michael hirz
und ich die spitzenkandidaten der
kleineren parteien die gute aussichten
haben in den bundestag einzuziehen hier
bei uns begrüßen den anfang heute macht
alice seidel von der alternative für
deutschland herzlich willkommen frau
meiner kfd das heißt alternative für
deutschland wo sehen sie sich denn auf
welchen feldern als alternative zu den
bestehenden parteien
es ist im grunde wie der name auch schon
sagt also unsere derzeitige
bundeskanzlerin hat uns ja damals schon
eingeschworen auf eine alternativlose
politik das fing mit der euro
rettungspolitik eben an die aus unserer
sicht rechtswidrig ist weil sie gegen
die europäischen verträge verstößt
woraufhin sich die afg auch gegründet
hat die euro rettungspolitik verstößt
maßgeblich gegen zwei artikeln in den
europäischen verträgen eben dass kein
staat für die schulden eines anderen
aufkommen darf und dass die ezb keine
staatsfinanzierung betreiben darf und
man tut das genaue gegenteil also darum
die alternative für deutschland eben
auch weil wir als einzige partei für
direktdemokratische teilhabe sind also
volksabstimmung referentinnen nach
schweizer vorbild und eben auch als ober
klammer unserer politik auch die
rechtsbrüche sehen dieser
bundesregierung nicht nur in der
dargelegten euro rettungspolitik sondern
auch in der derzeitigen flüchtlingskrise
aber nun sind ja viele der themen die
die gemüter erregt haben in den letzten
jahren also sie haben die euro krise
angesprochen
sie haben die flüchtlingsfrage
das sind ja themen die eigentlich
weitgehend abgeräumt sind und das thema
direkte demokratie das habe sicher auch
die grünen zum beispiel auf die fahnen
geschrieben
sie setzen das aber nicht um also auch
die grünen sind ja auch ein landes
verantwortung beispielsweise in meinem
schönen bundesland baden wird
da sieht man davon auch nicht so viel
also da muss man genau hinschauen was
die parteien so aussprechen an wünschen
und was nachher umgesetzt wird
da muss man schon darauf achten aber
auch die anderen themen sind ja
eigentlich behandelt
zumindest hat man den eindruck und wenn
man den umfragen trauen darf ist ja auch
das vertrauen zurückgekehrt in die
etablierten parteien
sie haben es gerade im grunde selber
gesagt man hat den eindruck dass diese
themen abgeräumt werden das ist mit
nicht der fall die eurokrise die spielt
weiter und zwar dadurch also
folgewirkungen ich nenne ihnen ein
beispiel sind explodierende
immobilienpreise vermögenspreisen den
städten die eine direkte folge wirkung
eine kehrseite der illegitimen euro
rettungspolitik ist also durch da die
durch die großen aufkaufprogramme der
ezb und der bilanzausweitung zwischen 60
und 80 milliarden monatlich das ist ja
die große bazooka von mario draghi ist
sehr viel liquidität im markt und diese
liquidität dieses geld sucht sich den
weg und das zuerst in die vermögen rein
also in die immobilien und das ist der
grund warum wir teilweise zweistellige
immobilien preissteigerungen großstädten
haben und der einfache arbeitnehmer und
bürger aus dem wohnungen ausgepreist
wird weil eben die löhne nicht
gleichermaßen eben steigen also wir
haben es hier mit einem realen
kaufkraftverlust zu tun von
arbeitnehmereinkommen und das führt
natürlich zwangsläufig zu einer riesigen
umverteilung und das und und das spüren
die bürger auch wenn man jetzt auf das
konto schaut es werden keine zinsen mehr
gezahlt die sparanlagen bringt keine
zinsen mehr und das ist eine kehrseite
der euro-rettung skride seite aber sie
haben mehrmals gesagt illegitim wer hat
das festgestellt gibt es irgendwelche
gerichte oder sonst jemand der
festgestellt hat dass bewegt sich
außerhalb der des rahmens der
legitimität
also erst mal hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht damals schon
gesagt diese diese outright monetary
transactions die sind hart an der grenze
also eigentlich schon in richtung das
ist eine staatsfinanzierung und
mittlerweile muss man sich ja auch
fragen was auch den gerichten geworden
ist was vor allen dingen auch den
europäischen gerichtshof anbelangt es
ist ganz klar zu konstatieren dass
beispielsweise gegen die no bail out
klausel die ganz klar sagt in den
europäischen verträgen dass kein staat
für die schulden eines anderen staates
aufkommen darf dass gegen diesen artikel
verstoßen wird und zwar durch
direkthilfen stichwort griechenland
paket und die europäische zentralbank
eben auch staatsfinanzierung betreibt
weil sich sie kauft ja nicht nur
staatsanleihen auf die nicht mehr
marktfähig sind sondern sie kauft
beispielsweise auch unternehmensanleihen
auf also ergo sie saugt sich mit
schlechten risiken voll die
schuldenstaaten können eine riesige
umschuldungs politik betreiben auf
kosten letztendlich der eigenkapital
eigner der ezb und auch der bundesbank
und das ist der deutsche steuerzahler
das ist aber bisher noch nicht als nicht
rechtens von den gerichten so
festgestellt worden aber wir würden
gerne noch andere themen mit ihnen
ansprechen einem thema zum beispiel die
innere sicherheit im rahmen der inneren
sicherheit fordern sie vor allen dingen
auch mehr polizisten mehr polizei das
fordert inzwischen ja fast alle parteien
muss der großen unterschied der große
unterschied ist zwischen den parteien
und uns ist das eigentlich viel
gesprochen wurde auch in den letzten
jahren aber gerade auch die parteien in
regierungsverantwortung und da beziehe
ich beispielsweise auch die fdp explizit
in den länderparlamenten mit 1 haben
eigentlich polizeistellen auf bundes-
aber auch auf länderebene gestrichen
also dass es auch etwas hier an eine
polizeireform auch einen paten
württemberg die polizeistellen
gestrichen hat also da ganz klar ein
haken natürlich gestrichen aber zu einem
zeitpunkt wo natürlich zum einen die
kriminalstatistik anders war die
flüchtlingskrise noch nicht so war
bei zahlen von circa 20.000 pro jahr und
erreichten das war natürlich noch mal
eine ganz andere situation als es heute
ist in der heutigen situation sagen die
anderen parteien ja wir müssen wieder
aufbauen vor einigen jahren haben sie
immer gesagt wir können abbauen weil an
anderen stellen das vielleicht gar nicht
mehr so notwendig war nur das als
einschub ja richtig also das ist ja auch
gut also dieser diese diese entwicklung
die hätte man aber auch vorhersehen
können das ist jetzt nicht so dass das
überraschend gewesen ist dass diese
flüchtlingsströme seit 2015 auf uns
einströmen sondern das war schon jahre
vorher absehbar und da fragen wir uns
eben auch warum man das übersehen hat
und nicht die konsequenzen gezogen hat
und die folgewirkungen haben wir jetzt
alle zu tragen jetzt noch mal zurück zur
inneren sicherheit das kann man jetzt
einfordern aber wir fragen uns eben auch
wo bleibt denn der effektive grenzschutz
da ist auch die afg wieder die einzige
partei die grenzkontrollen mit
personenkontrollen an unseren
außengrenzen fordert denn schengen ist
ja de facto geschenke gibt es jetzt seit
30 jahren und die grundvoraussetzung für
schenk ist ja gewesen dass die eu
außengrenzen gesichert werden und nur
dann die binnengrenzen zwischen den
europäischen staaten abgeschafft werden
können und jetzt haben wir die situation
jetzt schon seit über zwei jahren de
facto wo wir eine offene außengrenzen
habe aber immer noch offene grin
binnengrenzen pardon und da fordern wir
eben auch wir brauchen
personenkontrollen wir brauchen einen
effektiven grenzschutz und wir können
doch nicht zulassen dass uns menschen
kommen hunderttausende ohne
ausweispapiere von dem wir nicht wissen
wer sie sind und woher sie kommen und ob
sie überhaupt asylberechtigt oder
flüchtlings berechtigt sind noch mal
kurz zur inneren sicherheit weil das ist
ja flüchtlinge unterdessen ja schon die
außengrenzen ist er fast schon aus aber
innere sicherheit da geht es vor allen
dingen um kriminalität auch
da sagen aber auch alle parteien da
müssen wir ran da müssen wir was tun
also wo ist da die große alternative
kern an parteien sind leider die
verursacher des problems sind die
verursacher können niemals die lösung
für das problem sein diese große
koalition die jetzige bundesregierung
hat alle warnungen bereits seit 2005 10
2014 von sicherheits experten in den
wind geschlagen die davor gewarnt haben
dass die politik der offenen grenzen
erhebliche sicherheitsrisiken beinhaltet
und davor haben wir auch gewarnt und
jetzt stehen wir da wir haben eine
erodierte innere sicherheitslage in der
bundesrepublik deutschland studiert
sicherheitslage wie sie sagen darauf
zurück dass die flüchtlinge hier sind
ausschließt aber natürlich nicht
ausschließlich aber das ist ein so das
ist ein hauptgrund sie können das
verknüpfen das war das was noch 2015 und
2016 geleugnet wurde ist eigentlich
heute evident wenn wir uns die
polizeistatistiken anschauen und wenn
wir uns allein letztes jahr angucken
2016 dann ist die zahl der
tatverdächtigen asylbewerber um 53
prozent gestiegen und in der kategorie
mord haben wir eine verdoppelung der
tatverdächtigen asylbewerber innerhalb
von einem zeitraum von 365 tage ja gut
dass er aber dass das kann man nicht
tolerieren
wir können nicht tolerieren dass auch
vor allen dingen sie reden jetzt von
absoluten zahlen aber dann können wir es
auch ins verhältnis setzen zu zu den
deutschen
da muss man einfach sagen in sachen
gewaltverbrechen auch gegen die sexuelle
selbstbestimmung dann ist der
ausländeranteil 14 fast 15 mal höher auf
100000 als bei deutschen wenn wir jetzt
über relation sprechen wollen
und davor haben wir gewarnt von anfang
an und passiert ist bisher nichts und
immer noch nicht darum kann man das auch
sehr schön beobachten letztendlich wird
nichts passieren weil diejenigen die
jetzt am lautesten schreien sind ja in
der bundesregierung in der
regierungsverantwortung und es wird
immer noch nichts gemacht wir halten das
ich persönlich halte das auch für
unverantwortlich diese politik ich habe
immer auf das innenpolitische
klima in deutschland in diesen tagen was
auch zugenommen hat ist ja politisch
motivierte gewalt von links auch von
rechts und sie sind dann häufig
konfrontiert auch mit dem vorwurf dass
sie durch die radikalisierte rhetorik
auch gerade ihres kompagnons als
spitzenkandidat durch alexander gauland
aber auch leute wie herrn höcker den sie
ja auch schon mal gerne ausgeschlossen
gesehen hätten dass sie dieses klima
eben von potenzieller gewalt auch mit
anheizen
also zunächst einmal ist es ganz
eindeutig dass niemand dieses land so
gespalten hat gesellschaftlich wie diese
bundeskanzlerin
wir haben nach zwölf jahren
kanzlerschaft angela merkel ein zutiefst
gespaltenes land und das hat auch damit
zu tun dass sich diese bundesregierung
über recht und gesetz hinwegsetzen
das ist eben die oberklasse und das sind
auch übrigens gefährliche entwicklungen
im parlamentarismus und auch das
demokratische prinzip jetzt über recht
und gesetz hinwegsetzen ein beispiel das
weiß auf den euro oder bezogen also auch
auf die flüchtlingskrise schauen sie die
politik der offenen grenzen verstößt
gegen das deutsche asylgesetz gegen das
deutsche grundgesetz und gegen das
doppel in drei abkommen gegen das
europäische und das hat sogar der
europäische gerichtshof unserer
bundeskanzlerin bescheinigt also da
müssen wir mal ganz klar auch bei der
sache bleiben welche politik hier
betrieben wird im übrigen ohne mandat
das wird er nicht mal im bundestag wo
das ja diskutiert und da sagen wir ganz
klar das geht nicht und verstößt gegen
die demokratische teilhabe und wir
lehnen jede form des linken des rechten
extremismus und auch des islamischen
extremismus zutiefst ab das ist doch
ganz klar wir befinden uns hier in der
bundesrepublik deutschland wir haben ein
land auf das wir stolz sein können mit
einer freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung die jeder achten sollte und
auch im übrigen wenn im bundestag kampf
gegen rechts mit 100 millionen
steuergelder
auch teilweise der politische konkurrent
auch wir ausgeschaltet werden soll denn
sie müssen auch berücksichtigen dass
auch wir afd funktionäre und auch die
mitglieder mit massiven übergriffen oder
auch untergriffig keiten zu tun haben
auch physischer natur
es gibt aber auch das umgekehrte
phänomen die frage ist ja die sich
stellt wie ist denn ihre abgrenzung nach
rechts zum rechtsextremismus zum
rechtsradikalismus
auch wenn man auf bestimmte bewegung
coupé da die zumindest an ihren rändern
ja auch durchaus eine gewalttätige
komponente hat grenzen sie sich da nach
ihrer einschätzung genügend von ab
inwiefern hat pga eine gewalttätige ja
wenn ich daran denke an demonstrationen
wo er mit galgen hantiert wird an die
dann mitglieder der bundesregierung
aufgehängt werden sollen und so weit ich
glaube schon dass man mit fug und recht
können dem widersprechen das recht sein
kann dass da der stände dass da der der
übergang eben auch zu gewalttätigen
formen des rechtsradikalismus und
rechtsextremismus durchaus gegeben ist
ja ich wollte es einfach nur verstehen
was damit jetzt gemeint ist also richtig
also die afg ist eine politische partei
und pg da ist eine ganz andere sache
die afg hat nichts mit pg dazutun dazu
gibt es auch ein bundesvorstands
beschluss soll das ist ja das
exekutivorgane unserer partei der
bundesvorstand und wir sind eine
politische partei auf basis eines
wahlprogramme ist eines
grundsatzprogramms das 80 seiten beträgt
über alle politischen handlungsfelder
und das ist unser programm
aber sie haben ja auch gelegentlich
mitglieder jetzt gerade aktuell wieder
die sie ausschließen müssen weil genau
da eben diese grenzüberschreitung
stattfinden also die sich dann eben
nicht halten wieder an die vorgaben des
grundgesetzes noch an ihr postulat dass
sie eben geäußert haben nicht nicht
umsonst gibt es ja auch
parteiordnungsverfahren und auch da
vielleicht bei einem fall der sofortige
parteiaustritte das wird nicht goutiert
dass wir doch nicht toleriert
das haben andere parteien aber auch
schauen sie unsere
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen eder tee
oder gegen ein thilo sarrazin von spd
und diese einzelfälle die haben sie in
ein paar tagen
sie haben oder wir haben eben schon
gehört dass sie das thema innere
sicherheit sehr stark auch mit dem thema
migration verknüpfen
sie sprechen dann oft auch von von einer
art dreiklang ausweisung abschiebung und
ausbürgerung für die migranten
beziehungsweise asylanten oder auch für
diejenigen die hier ins land gekommen
sind wie sie auch gesagt haben teilweise
illegalen dieses land gekommen sind
inwiefern sind das dinge die mit unserem
grundgesetz überhaupt vereinbar sind vor
allen dingen wenn man das thema
ausbürgerung anspricht sie haben jetzt
gerade ausreise und ausbildungen in
einem atemzug genannt also das muss man
differenzieren zunächst einmal müssen
wir rein rechtlich festhalten dass wir
mittlerweile seit 2005 10 bis heute rund
630.000 ausreisepflichtige per gesetz
eben auch haben und das sind rein
zahlenmäßig sind das sechs großstädte in
der bundesrepublik deutschland die
ausreisepflichtig sind
und sie sind immer noch hier und sie
werden eben nicht abgeschoben also wir
erinnern uns auch daran dass die cdu
letztes jahr gesagt hat der nationale
kraftakt oder die kraftanstrengung hat
dazu geführt dass eigentlich 2017 noch
weniger menschen abgeschoben wurden die
eigentlich ausreisepflichtig sind als
2016 also da haben auch die
regierungsparteien nicht vollzogen was
sie angekündigt haben und das ist eine
rechtsdurchsetzung wir fordern eine
rechtsdurchsetzung an denn wir
beobachten ganz genau wir nun als nur
ganz ganz kurz was ich was ich sehr
erstaunlich bei dieser debatte finde ich
stelle mir die frage wann wurde bei
einem deutschen staatsbürger eine
steuernachzahlung nicht vollzogen oder
der entzug des führerscheins nicht
vollstreckt und urplötzlich haben wir
630.000 ausreisepflichtige die in
unserem land leben die aber nicht
abgeschoben werden
das ist etwas was ich rein logisch
nein 630.000 seit 2005 10 das hat sich
ja kumuliert wir reden nur von diesem
jahr von einer kumulation von 227.000
wie wollen sie so etwas organisieren das
ist eine große zahl
wir stellen fest dass teilweise
asylbewerber oder menschen die eben
einen eine abschiebung eine abschiebung
bescheid bekommen haben dass die von den
flugzeugen und den piloten gar nicht
transportiert werden nicht mitgenommen
werden weil sie dort war der pilot sich
schlicht weigert sie mitzunehmen
ästhetisch zb aber wie wollen sie das
organisieren das ist eine gigantische
zahl wie wollen sie diese menschen
tatsächlich abschieben es ist ja nicht
so dass die bundesländer sich nicht
bemühen die leute abzuschieben das gibt
es in großer zahl aber wie würden sie es
organisieren was würden sie anders
machen
das kann ich ihnen erklären denn der
häufigste grund einer nicht abschiebung
sind fehlende ausweispapiere
das heißt im ergebnis dass menschen in
unser land hinein kommen ohne
ausweispapiere aber nicht mehr
abgeschoben werden können weil sie keine
ausweispapiere haben also das heißt das
ventil ist nur nach so in eine richtung
offen was fast völliger irrsinn ist wenn
sie mich fragen und darum sagen wir
erstens wir brauchen eine effektive
grenzsicherung unserer außengrenzen wir
müssen die menschen kontrollieren
denn er wäre mir jetzt um die menschen
und helsana es ist extrem wichtig wenn
wir nach dem anschauen wollt ihr jetzt
wissen was sie mit den menschen die
konkret hier sind die ein abschiebe
bescheid haben wie würden sie das
organisieren alle diese menschen in ihre
herkunftsländer oder ich dich länder
zurück tja aber eine abschiebung macht
keinen sinn wenn man keine
grenzsicherung hat weil sie können
jederzeit zurückkommen ansehen darum
trotzdem sind ziemlich viele der setzen
müssten es ist eben ganz wichtig dass
auch mit zu verknüpfen weil es zu einem
gesamtkonzept zum schutz der deutschen
zivilbevölkerung auch mit gehört
so kann man das organisieren also erst
mal ist das aufgabe der bundespolizei
und von spezialisten
oder auch der der polizei und vielleicht
auch letztendlich der bundeswehr
diese fragen zu beantworten wie man
diese menschen abschieben kann also das
ist
primäre aufgabe der der polizei
sie haben keine konkrete idee also dass
die polizei jetzt machen soll
also entschuldigen sie bitte sie müssen
auch logistisch ist organisatorisch
natürlich ist es logistisches
organisatorisches problem aber das
problem hätte sich niemals gestellt wenn
man überhaupt unsere punkte umgesetzt
hätte dann wären wir gar nicht an dem
punkt aber stattdessen setzt man sich
eben mit unserer programmatik nicht
auseinander und der der punkt ist doch
einfach wenn menschen nicht abgeschoben
werden können weil sie zu gewalttätig
sind in zivilen maschinen dann packt man
sie eben im militärmaschinen hinein weil
mir kann niemand sagen dass menschen
nicht abgeschoben werden können weil sie
sich daneben benehmen in einer zivil
maschine im übrigen müssen sie sich mal
ich habe es getan mit einem lufthansa
piloten unterhalten was da teilweise los
ist und wir hätten diese menschen erst
gar nicht wenn wir vernünftige
grenzsicherung betreiben würden darum
wollen wir das ja auch und ich finde es
auch unverantwortlich dass eine maschine
mit kriminellen afghanen per hand die
hier straftaten begehen auch nicht
abheben konnte weil irgendwelche sich
daneben benommen haben also da muss man
sich wirklich fragen was hier betrieben
wird fakt ist sie müssen diese menschen
abschieben
und wenn sie gewalttäter mit dabei haben
dann helfen auch elektronische
fußfesseln
beim thema abschiebung fehlt natürlich
aus der jüngsten geschichte der afg auch
einen satz 1 den ihr kollege im
spitzenteam alexander gauland gesagt hat
und zwar bezogen auf die
staatsministerin usus die für
integration zuständig ist
die einen satz gesagt hat über den man
sicher streiten kann
aber er hat gesagt er wolle sie nach
nach anatolien entsorgen nun ist das
eine eine dame die in
hamburg geboren worden ist deutsche
staatsbürgerin ist von geburt an
ich denke mal auch aus ihrer sicht
bestens integriert was für einem konzept
von staatsbürgerschaft folgen sie da
also bei dieser ganzen debatte kann man
sehr schön beobachten mit welchen
doppelstandards hier gearbeitet wird
sigmar gabriel hat 2012 noch gesagt man
müsste die bundesregierung rückstandslos
entsorgen
da gab es kein aufschrei sobald der
gauland sagt entsorgen oder habe
irgendein fdp politiker dann hat man
gleich die mediale mühle also hier wird
wirklich mit zweierlei maß gemessen
und man kann kann man das wirklich
vergleichen ihre natürlichkeit kann sich
das ja in bereichen meister gleich um
eine in der es geht hier um eine ganz
bestimmte person die offensichtlich so
wie sie es formulieren nach ihren
vorstellungen hier in diesem land nicht
erwünscht ist und die man zurück
schicken sollte zurück in
anführungszeichen weil ein zurück gibt
es für sie ja gar nicht
sie ist ja deutsche und sie ist in
deutschland geboren ja das ist ja auch
schön für focus darum muss man sich die
frage stellen warum sie eigentlich so
ein weltbild hat und da muss man sich
tatsächlich oder da stelle ich mir bei
frau ist chris die frage ob es sich
vielleicht auch bei den werten die sie
vertritt als integrationsministerin weil
man sich einfach mal ein
integrationspapier vom letzten jahr
angeschaut hat für unsere werte
dann würde man ja auch nicht sagen wir
entsorgen die nach anatolien film ich
hätte gar nicht mit ihnen streiten über
den betrieb entsorgen aber es geht darum
dass man jemanden der hier geboren ist
in ein fremdes land schicken will
also ihnen sozusagen aus bürgern
was sehr gut gesetzt nicht gar nicht
möglich ist es ist eine rhetorische
spitze gewesen die sich andere politiker
auch ständig bedienen
und wenn man sich die standpunkte vom
frühstücks als integrationsministerin
anschaut das ist eine deutsche kultur
jenseits der sprache nicht gäbe und dazu
dass integrationspapier nimmt und auch
im übrigen die toleranz von kindern als
religiöses recht in deutschland
dann muss man sich wirklich die frage
stellen ob das weltbild von einer frau
ybbs in ihrer funktion überhaupt
vereinbar ist mit dem deutschen
grundgesetz und da muss ich ihn ganz
klar sagen ich sehe das nicht so es ist
unvereinbar mit unserem grundgesetz mit
unserer freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung
wir müssen anerkennen dass ist schon
eben einen unterschied macht das
natürlich eben auch kommentiert wird mit
rassismus dann in dem fall weil wie
gesagt frau schmidt aus köln würde die
würde man auch nicht nach anatolien
entsorgen oder zurückschicken weil die
kommt wie der name schon sagt punkt die
seit generationen sind die familie aus
köln und nicht aus anatolien leichter
einen trennten feindlicher ton
mitschwingt das können wir eine die nun
ein es ist es bezieht sich ganz klar auf
ihre funktion als
integrationsbeauftragte und ich glaube
nicht dass eine frau schmidts oder frau
müller aus köln oder hamburg behaupten
würde das ist keine kultur jenseits
keine deutsche kultur jenseits der
deutschen sprache gebe oder dass man
kinder in deutschland toleriert ehen mit
minderjährigen als religiöses recht man
muss sich mal ganz genau die vita und
die standpunkte dieser person angucken
da muss ich ihn auch ganz klar sagen ich
frage mich wieso jemand es überhaupt die
bundesregierung geschafft hat ich finde
das wirklich intolerabel das sind
verantwortlich so kann man ja politisch
argumentieren das ist ja völlig legitim
nur gesagt sie würden sie ja nicht nach
das ist schon ein unterschied ob man
sagt man entsorgt jemand nach anatolien
oder sagte deutsche rück gehen nach habe
jetzt gerade
haben wir aber gut ich habe die
standpunkte sind ausgetauscht
ja ich würde ich würde gerne auch mal in
den blick nach vorne
ein wenig wagen auch bezüglich der
flüchtlinge sie haben dieses jahr 2015
entsprechend kritisiert sie haben gesagt
was sie sich vorstellen was alles getan
werden muss um flüchtlingsströme eben
auch einzudämmen
wir haben jetzt die situation dass die
balkanroute im prinzip zu ist wir haben
die situation dass wir all türkei
abkommen haben sodass eigentlich so gut
wie gar keine flüchtlinge mehr bei uns
ankommen oder nur sehr wenige
flüchtlinge ankommen ist das der
richtige weg
also die flüchtlingszahlen oder die
flüchtlingskrise ist ja gar nicht
durchgestanden im wir hatten jetzt
edition sind natürlich nicht
vergleichbar mit dem bis 2015 jeder gut
aber wird für die zweite jahreshälfte
bis ende 2017 werde er wieder steigende
zahlen prognostiziert also ich bin ja
mal gespannt
ja wenn das erste halbe jahr 2007
dann sind das ja ok geringe zahl gut
dann kommt noch der familiennachzug 2018
märz das erste mal ausgesetzt ja richtig
aber der ist ja auch nicht ohne grund
ausgesetzt und darum greift er ja auch
direkt nach der bundestagswahl
da wird uns ja auch nicht reiner wein
eingeschenkt mit wie vielen leuten wir
eigentlich zu rechnen haben es sind
nämlich 390.000 syrer alleine die ihre
familien nachziehen können größtenteils
eben junge junge politische flüchtlinge
und was da auf uns zukommt wenn wir den
faktor vier oder fünf nehmen sind das
zwei millionen menschen zusätzlich
allein aus den jahren 2015 und 16 also
da und und da kommen ja andere
flüchtlingsgruppen ja auch noch mit dazu
also was diese unverantwortliche weil
rein quantitativ geht doch die rechnung
gar nicht auf wenn sie mich fragen
jeder von uns möchte aus humanitärem
interesse menschen in not helfen das ist
doch außer frage
so aber wir müssen das nachhaltig tun
und sie können die probleme dieser welt
nicht innerhalb unserer landesgrenzen
innerhalb des deutschen sozialstaates
lösen weil es sind einfach zu viele es
geht quantitativ nicht auf und darum
haben wir auch anfang der letzten woche
unser asyl und entwicklungspolitisches
konzept vorgestellt was auch ganz klar
vorsieht
sie haben gerade gesagt balkan route ist
gestört
genau weil nämlich leute wie orban auch
ihrem auftrag nachkommen sind gesetze
einzuhalten
dafür wurden sie von unserer kanzlerin
noch kritisiert man muss sich diese
doppelmoral auch vorstellen und wir
sagen ganz klar muss die mittelmeerroute
schließen
man muss die menschen die man aus dem
mittelmeer rettet wieder zurückbringen
an die nordafrikanische küste und wir
haben einen europäischen
sonderbeauftragten gefordert aus der
kommen ja von der nordafrikanischen
küste kommen noch welche es geht
abkommen auch mit libyen
dort werden die menschen direkt wieder
auch zurückgeschickt das reiche nicht so
ist sind kaum noch menschen die wirklich
durchkommen in anführungszeichen ja aber
man muss so man muss da viel
nachhaltiger herangehen ich wollte es
ihnen gerade schildern
wir fordern einen sonderbeauftragten der
europäischen union
da eben genau das mit den
maghreb-staaten auch mit den
nordafrikanischen anrainerstaaten
aushandeln muss und zwar kurzfristig
asylzentren in den menschen flüchtlinge
humanitär erstmal untergebracht werden
können und dann mittel bis langfristig
schutzzentren für menschen auf der
flucht und das ganze ist zu besichern
mit
hilfe der vereinten nationen und auch
unter blauhelm einsatz und das ist das
was wir schon lange fordern denn man
kann keine vernünftige flüchtlings und
asylpolitik betreiben ohne eben auch
nachhaltig entwicklungspolitische
ansätze zu haben
zur hilfe zu kommen zur hilfe zur
selbsthilfe in den afrikanischen
anrainerstaaten was aber andere parteien
ja auch vorgeschlagen haben und das auch
umgesetzt haben wieder nicht denn das
was ich gerade angesprochen habe auch
mit den asylzentren das karma von otto
schily ursprünglich es hat er schon 2003
oder 2004 gesagt sowie 13 jahre weiter
es ist nichts passiert in diese richtung
soviel dazu auch wenn es jetzt von
thomas de maizière aufgegriffen wird er
ja auch vollmundig auch sagt dass wir
werden mit dem terror leben müssen weil
wir unsere ganzen nicht sichern gemacht
wird letztendlich nichts europa hat
schon ein paar mal in unserem gespräch
eine rolle gespielt schauen wir mal auf
europa sie gelten ja als eine partei die
das nationale sehr akzentuiert also
heraushebt wir haben aber nicht erst
seit maastricht eine entwicklung hin zu
einem einigen europa aus vielen gründen
schien das ob frieden oder geopolitische
bedeutung
scheint das ja auch keine schlechte idee
zu sein
wollen sie das jetzt zurückdrehen und
wollen sie zurück zu einem nationalstaat
in der prägung des neunzehnten
jahrhundert also was wir zunächst einmal
wollen ist weniger europäische union
denn wir sehen hier auch ganz klar
demokratie defizite wenn sich die
institutionen der europäischen union
einmal anschauen dann haben sie mit der
kommission ein exekutivorgan das
gleichzeitig legislative initiativrecht
hat das nur parlamenten vorbehalten ist
das heißt sie haben dort eine
durchbrechung der horizontalen
gewaltenteilung die eben demokratien und
dem parlamentarismus zu eigen ist
und wenn dann noch die komponente mit
dazu kommt dass europäisches also
supranationales recht nationales recht
bricht wo die gewählten parlamente eben
auch sitzen wie jetzt eben auch im
deutschen bundestag
dann sehen wir dort wirklich eine
durchbrechung eine gefährdung des
demokratischen prinzips den in den
staaten wie frankreich italien
deutschland und so weiter sitzen die
gewählten parlamente und wir fordern als
ersten schritt erst mal ein vetorecht
für die einzelnen länder gegenüber
brüssel davor gaben
das hat den vorteil dass sie auch wieder
standort wettbewerb unter den ländern
haben wenn sie abweichen können
und darum ist eigentlich unsere
stoßrichtung weniger zentralisierung
mehr dezentralisierung damit sie auch
mehr wettbewerb innerhalb der
europäischen union auch haben also ein
so ein wettkampf auch von systemen und
auch von staaten sowie wir im vorjahr
hatten das hat auch wunderbar
funktioniert der binnenmarkt hat uns
allen wohlstand gebracht und
arbeitsteiliges wirtschaften möglich
gemacht bleiben aber natürlich ja mit
einer einschränkung aber das muss das
würde ich gerne noch ausführen ja
freizügigkeit von denn wir sehen ganz
klar auch hier
für den sozialhilfe oder arbeitslosen
betrug muss auch ganz klar das
ursprungsland prinzip gelten dass was
wir eben auch verordnet haben die
menschen die sozialhilfe beziehen
sollten sie in ihrem ursprungsland
beziehen wenn sie da vorher eingezahlt
haben und nicht im zielland weil das
führt dann dazu dass die situation die
wir eben heute haben ja dass sehr viele
osteuropäische zuwanderer die er noch
nicht gearbeitet haben direkt
sozialhilfe beziehen können und das
lehnen sie ab und sie sagten eben die
situation vor ein paar jahren hätte ja
gut funktioniert also die forderung mehr
nationalstaat weniger eu sind wir dann
nicht heute schon einige jahre weiter in
richtung globalisierung und würde
deutschland bei einem solchen bau einer
solchen neuordnung nicht marginalisiert
auch in der welt sind wir dazu nicht
letztendlich zu klein
das hat eigentlich vorher auch sehr gut
funktioniert das auch einige jahre
weiter ja aber wir müssen uns vorstellen
wohin das eigentlich alles geführt hat
also selbst der außenhandels anteil der
bundesrepublik deutschland in den
euroraum hat mit einführung des euro ist
ja nicht zugenommen sondern abgenommen
das wird ja auch immer vergessen dass
wird der allgemeinen gesagt dass
deutschland auch von dem euro und von
europa profitiert hätte was mitnichten
der fall ist unser außenhandels anteil
in die eurozone ist seit der
euro-einführung um kumulativ also
zusammengenommen fast zehn prozent
zurückgegangen
und wir waren vorher bevor wir den euro
eben hatten als wir die binnenmarkt
prinzipien hatten zusammen mit der
europäischen währung schlange aber dann
auch mit dem europäischen währungssystem
mit dem ebs system waren wir deutlich
besser aufgestellt wie flexible
wechselkurse hatten und dadurch dass
jetzt der nominale
wechselkursmechanismus weggefallen ist
können wir nur noch real angleichen und
das entfacht eigentlich fliehkräfte die
jetzt heute sehen durch massive
öffentliche kapitaltransfers in eine
riesige umverteilung und letztendlich
auch ein
eine eine erosion der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit
bleiben wir bei der wirtschaft im
augenblick machen ja viele szenarien die
runde was die zukunft der arbeitswelt
angeht stichwort digitalisierung
da gibt es eine studie die sogenannte
oxford studie die sagt also ein großteil
der arbeitsplätze die wir heute kennen
oder auch der der berufsbilder die wir
heute kennen wird es in den kommenden
jahren nicht mehr geben die sind teil
der vergangenheit mit welchen konzepten
treten sie an um das thema
digitalisierung modernisierung zu
schaffen und gleichzeitig aber zu
verhindern dass es zu
massenarbeitslosigkeit und also zum
thema digitalisierung ist es ganz klar
wir müssen das netz ausbauen
das glasfasernetz das beinhaltet
erhebliche investitionen weil es ist
einfach zu langsam
und dieses phänomen dass urplötzlich
arbeitsplätze wegfallen würden das
hatten wir schon auch in den 60er 70er
80er jahren wurden viele viele bücher
geschrieben dass aufgrund der
automatisierung arbeitsplätze wegfallen
und das ist ja alles nicht passiert weil
sie durch eine modernisierung der
arbeitswelt auch eben
produktivitätssteigerungen und
veränderungen geben haben die das eben
auch mit abfedern also so ein
strukturwandel der vollzieht sich auch
immer sehr langsam und dadurch verändern
sich eben auch die berufsbilder aber es
kreiert nicht arbeitslosigkeit das wurde
bisher empirisch nachgewiesen
hier kann sie beruhigen im moment ist
die arbeitslosigkeit ja auch auf einem
sehr niedrigen stand und wir haben eher
einen größeren fachkräftemangel in
unserem land wenn wir über
fachkräftemangel sprechen sprechen wir
oft auch oder parteien sprechen in dem
zusammenhang oft auch von zuwanderung
von einwanderung brauchen wir
tatsächlich ein einwanderungsgesetz das
brauchen wir unbedingt
wir brauchen qualifizierte zuwanderung
denn wir können auch beobachten
deutschland ist zu einem
einwanderungsland leider von geringen
nicht qualifizierten geworden wenn man
ja die daten des statistischen
bundesamtes anschaut und zu einem
auswanderungsland von hochqualifizierten
die gehen vornehmlich in die usa und in
die schweiz
und darum brauchen wir ein
einwanderungsgesetz was ganz klar
ausgerichtet ist beispielsweise nach dem
kanadischen oder nach dem australischen
einwanderungssystem ein punktesystem was
ich nach qualifikation richtet
sprachfähigkeit integrationsfähigkeit
und müdigkeit und sich ganz klar nach
den interessen des deutschen
arbeitsmarktes ausrichtet das sind sie
sehr nah bei der spd also vielleicht die
spd nah an uns weil wir haben das immer
schon gesagt und jetzt hat die spd das
ist wahrscheinlich als wahlkampfthema
entdeckt
das haben wir immer schon gesagt ihre
partei ist für vieles bekannt aber nicht
dafür dass sie ein besonders
fortschrittliches familienbild vertritt
wie bringen sie diese dieses
familienbild das in ihrem programm auf
scheint aber auch in vielen reden wie
bringen sie das in einklang dann mit
denen auch erfordernissen einmal eines
anspruchs von frauen selbstständig und
eigenverantwortlich auch beruflich tätig
zu werden und gleichzeitig eben die
ansprüche einer gesellschaft an eben
auch fachkräfte es gibt ja sehr viele
gut ausgebildete frauen die durchaus
ihren anspruch auf einen arbeitsplatz
und ob eine berufliche befriedigende
tätigkeit ausüben wollen
die fühlen sich aber vermutlich von
ihrer partei nicht besonders angezogen
das können wir auch beobachten in den
wahlen also wir haben einen geringen
frauenanteil der liegt bei knapp 20
prozent also nur 20 prozent der frauen
wählen uns und er hat ja fde da haben
wir wirklich nachholbedarf das müssen
wir erklären genau das was sie
angesprochen haben die vereinbarkeit
beispielsweise von beruf und familie
denn wir haben ja nicht nur frauen die
arbeiten wollen
und das mit einem familienleben
vereinbaren wollen sondern die auch
arbeiten müssen beispielsweise zum
beispiel die alleinerziehende
krankenschwester die muss ja auch
arbeiten und da gebe ich sogar den
kritikern recht
das müssen wir nach bearbeiten um auch
diesen frauen auch eine antwort zu geben
wie wir das machen wollen also wir sagen
auch ganz klar gut kostenlose
kindergartenplätze
ich hatte in meinem wahlprogramm letztes
jahr zu den landtagswahlen eben auch
kostenlose kitaplätze kita und
kindergartenplätze aber das muss einfach
nochmal ausgerollten diskutiert werden
aber im allgemeinen ist ja so dieses das
was sie gerade geschildert haben so
dieses etwa etwas rückwärts gewandte
image das kann ich so dass väter
teilweise abgeleitet aus der aus dem
treiber der familienförderung wir wollen
den familien fördern und das kann ich
dann nur noch also etwas weniger
nachvollziehen weil wir sehen wirklich
nachholbedarf in der familienpolitik
also wir fordern beispielsweise auch das
bundesverfassungsgerichts urteile
umgesetzt werden
die anrechnung von erziehungszeiten auf
kranken und auf die rentenversicherung
das ist ja auch eine familie
förderungspolitik das fordern wir das
sagt auch das bundesverfassungsgericht
und auch da bleiben uns die anderen
parteien immer auch noch auch noch in
regierungsverantwortung eine antwort
schuldig wir fordern auch als afd ein
familiensplitting also einen übergang
von einem ehegatten splitting hinüber zu
einem familiensplitting modell das
beinhaltet dass die einkommenssteuer
sind proportional zur kinderzahl um
familie neben einkommen steuerlich
entlasten zu können und
das ist etwas das ist ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal der afd
aber ich gebe ihnen natürlich da auch
recht die beantwortung der frage von
familie und beruf da müssen wir in der
tat noch mal ran und in uns gehen welche
antworten wir da bereitstellen also das
gehört zum kernbestand des programm ist
also dieses sehr tradierte bild und sie
stehen mit ihrer biografie eigentlich
komplett dagegen weil sie sind jung
berufstätig erfolgreich sie leben mit
einer partnerin sie haben also auch
familie im erweiterten familien sinne
aber nicht im traditionellen also ist
das nicht auch schwierig also da werden
sie davor bot in jeder anderen partei
besser aufgehoben
eigentlich nicht also im denn es gilt
das prinzip der wahlfreiheit und der
gerechtigkeit in der familienpolitik
also die afg also wir sagen ja ganz klar
jeder kann so glücklich werden
nach seiner eigenen fasson das ist ja
die wahlfreiheit und wenn wir uns die
zahlen anschauen in deutschland dann
muss man einfach sagen drei viertel der
paare leben in einer heterosexuellen ehe
fast neun millionen kinder wachsen bei
ihren leiblichen eltern auf die eine ehe
geschlossen haben das sind nun einfach
mal die zahlen
und dass ich mich privat anders
entschieden habe weil ich auch gar nicht
anders kann das heißt ja noch lange
nicht dass ich jetzt gegen die familie
wäre ganz im gegenteil als politikerin
muss ich doch die familie als tragendes
element als fundament unserer
gesellschaft ja im blick haben und dass
so das ist ja auch gefordert und das
wollen wir eben auch machen durch ein
familiensplitting modell einrechnung der
erziehungszeiten das ist ja auch gegeben
und das ist auch erforderlich denn
bundesverfassungsgerichts urteil wir
gerade schon dargelegt sie werden
einfach nicht umgesetzt und das wollen
wir gerne
wir sind quasi am schluss unserer
sendung deswegen noch eine frage am 24.9
wird gewählt keiner will mit ihnen
koalieren von denen
jährigen parteien gehen sie da als reine
protestpartei in den bundestag wenn sie
den einzug schaffen
wir sind natürlich auch protest das ist
klar und es schade dass niemand mit uns
koalieren will aber es ist nun mal so
damit müssen wir jetzt umgehen
dementsprechend werden wir
oppositionspartei den prognosen nach
werden wir es höchstwahrscheinlich als
drittstärkste kraft also da sind uns
auch beispielsweise auch wichtige plätze
sicher beispielsweise im
haushaltsausschuss auf denen ich mich
bereits reue und da muss man einfach mal
weitersehen wie wie es dann in vier
jahren bei den nächsten bundestagswahlen
weitergeht
damit sind wir tatsächlich schon am ende
unserer sendungen vielen dank für das
gespräch
wir setzen die gespräche fort mit den
spitzenkandidaten der kleineren parteien
die aber aus sicht haben in den
bundestag zu kommen die jetzt anstehen
dankeschön vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]